blue origin is often written off as just
a copy of spacex
who doesn't accomplish nearly as much
aside from this
the negative image that is often
associated with jeff bezos
doesn't help the company's case very
much either but
what exactly is blue origin even working
on what are their plans for space
and how much progress have they made
well starting off we have their new
shepard rocket
this is a relatively small rocket coming
in at just 60 feet
or about one-fourth the height of
spacex's falcon 9 rocket
technically blue origin would become the
first company to land a rocket booster
safely
after the new shepard booster landed in
prior to this spacex had already
completed successful landings
using their boosters but they hadn't yet
succeeded in landing a booster
after a space flight so new shepard
did take this title however there are
several differences between spacex's
landings
and the blue origins landings that
should be noted if i don't want to get
destroyed
in the comments section first of all the
masses of the rocket
are radically different blue origin has
not revealed the mass of their new
shepard rocket
but considering that it is only 1 4 of
the height of falcon 9
it's likely significantly lighter on top
of this
the new shepherd's boosters start
returning to earth much earlier than
falcon 9's boosters
new shepard's boosters start heading
back at 100 kilometers in altitude
while falcon 9's boosters don't start to
descend till 200 kilometers in altitude
consequently
the falcon 9 booster is not only much
heavier
but it's traveling considerably faster
as well
new shepard reaches up to mach 3 during
its flight
while falcon 9 reaches between mach 5.5
and
mach 7 before its booster starts to
descend
with all that being said spacex's
landings are much more difficult as musk
pointed out
but new shepard's booster landings are
quite impressive
nonetheless aside from being fully
reusable
the new shepherd is expected to help
pioneer the space tourism business
their capsule has a volume of 15 cubic
meters
or 530 cubic feet and it is expected to
fit up to six people
at a time the entire flight is only
expected to last 11 minutes
with about 4 being above the karman line
or in space
ticket prices are estimated to be about
200 thousand dollars
as a result the most direct competitor
to the service
would of course be virgin galactic
virgin galactic space tourism tickets
also come in at 200 000 to 250 000
and they also only provide a couple of
minutes of space time
so the ticket price and space-time value
are quite similar
however the vastly different launch and
landing systems will likely sway
customers to prefer one
or the other currently new shepard has
completed
seven successful test flights mostly
just carrying research equipment
blue origin was originally planning to
launch a crew test flight
using the new shepard by the end of 2020
but
that has since been pushed back
considering that the rocket does seem to
be breathing through its test flights
however
it's just a matter of time until they
get to crude flights
likely in 2021 or 2022
moving on from the new shepard we have
blue origin's upcoming new glen rocket
the new glenn is a much more large-scale
rocket coming in
at about 95 meters it still falls about
20 meters short of a spacex's upcoming
starship rocket
but it's no doubt a behemoth
consequently
the new glenn has a payload capacity of
45 metric tons to low earth orbit
and 13 metric tons to geostationary
transfer orbit
they also claim that new glen's 7 meter
fairing provides twice the payload
volume
of any existing launch vehicle today and
the new glenn booster is expected to be
able to last 25 launches
till very recently a good portion of new
glenn was being funded by the air force
blue origin had won a 500 million
contract from the air force in october
of 2018 which was supposed to be spread
over the next six years
but in august of 2020 the air force
would select united launch alliance
and spacex to provide the air force with
launches over the next five years
unfortunately for blue origin the 500
million dollar contract specified that
blue origin
must remain a chosen launch provider for
the air force to continue receiving
payouts
obviously given jeff bezos wealth and
willingness to splurge on blue origin
the development of new glenn is in no
jeopardy due to this decision
however i'm sure the principle that the
air force chose spacex
and ula over blue origin was a downer
for the company
so far the company has invested 2.5
billion dollars into the development of
new glenn
and they do have a couple of customers
lined up such as teleset
oneweb and sky perfect anyways
looking forward blue origin still plans
on launching the new glen for the first
time
in 2021 if we were to be conservative
it may end up taking until 2022 or 2023
but in the grand scheme of things a
rocket should be completed in the
short-term future
once completed new glenn will become
blue origin's first
orbital launch vehicle as new shepard is
thus far
only a suborbital launch vehicle as a
result
this will likely be blue origin's first
step in flying commercial crews to the
international space station
given their superior payload volume
they'll likely be able to carry more
crew members to space station in one
flight than
ever before more importantly this rocket
will provide blue origin with a gateway
to crude moon missions
which brings us onto their next major
project the blue moon
the blue moon is a liquid hydrogen
liquid oxygen fueled moon lander
that comes in at 15 metric tons when
fully loaded with fuel
aside from this the blue moon is
designed to be able to deliver a solid
3.6
metric tons to the lunar surface they're
also expected to have a larger variant
as well
which will be capable of carrying up to
6.5 metric tons
before delving into crude moon missions
the blue moon
is expected to be used on a variety of
different research experiments
on the lunar surface the blue moon is
even capable of releasing small
satellites into orbit
around the moon anyways one several of
these research experiments have been
completed
thus proving the reliability of blue
moon it is expected to be used on crude
missions
the regular blue moon is only designed
to make one ray troops to the moon
in order to maximize the payload volume
however the larger variant will also
carry sufficient fuel
as well as an ascent module to enable
round trips to the moon
the blue moon is expected to be used in
conjunction with the new glen
but that's not the only use case nasa
is also expected to use the blue moon
nasa's current plan
is to return people to the moon in 2024
using its upcoming space launch system
considering that space launch system
itself
has quite a bit of development still
left to go the plan
is to use blue moon to land astronauts
on the moon
as opposed to building their own new
lunar landing system
so that's everything that blue origin is
working on today
but what about their future what are
blue origin's long-term goals
well blue origin does believe in
establishing a lunar base
and possibly a lunar colony however
their main goal is not space
colonization
though they are all for it taking a look
at blue origin's mission page they
detail that it is their goal to preserve
earth and tap into space's unlimited
resources
and energy you see jeff bezos believes
that earth is
by far the best planet and as a result
we should focus on staying on and
preserving earth while using space
and other planets to better serve us
rather than trying to live there
like i said though he is all for space
colonization
but he doesn't think it's a top priority
according to him the largest threat to
human advancement
and innovation is not an existential
threat
like a meteor destroying earth or
something like that
but rather an energy crisis he describes
quote
we will run out of energy this is just
arithmetic
it's going to happen he explains that
our bodies
are as efficient as 100 watt light bulbs
despite this as a society the average
person
living in western countries consumes
about 11 000 watts
or the same energy needed to sustain 110
humans
as the energy demand in western
countries continues to grow
and developing countries catch up he
believes that we will have to resort
to rationing our energy consequently he
believes that the solution to this
conundrum is expanding energy production
into space this may consist of setting
up large solar panels
in space or nearby planets these solar
panels will store their produce energy
on battery devices which will be
transported back and forth
this of course requires that the energy
produced by such solar panels
far exceeds the energy consumed in
transporting energy to the earth
currently our solar technology is
nowhere near enough to reasonably offset
the energy consumed by rocket launches
but a few decades in the future this
vision might actually make sense
aside from this jeff bezos also believes
that another pressing concern
here on earth is of course air pollution
and to combat this in addition to
converting as many industries as
possible
to clean energy he believes that
industries that cannot be converted
should also be moved
into space at the end of the day blue
origin
is currently working on making their new
shepard rocket ready for crude missions
concurrently they're also looking to
finish development of the new
glenn and the blue moon to expedite the
journey in setting up a lunar base
long term though they hope to offset the
energy and pollution crisis
on earth by moving energy production and
manufacturing
into space and that's the state of blue
origin
today do you guys agree that energy
constraints will turn into a large scale
problem in the future
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys love competition in the
space industry and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you